[Musik]
jahr für jahr beginnen mehr als 100.000
menschen ein neues leben in der schweiz
was bringt sie dazu ihre heimat zu
verlassen und in der schweiz neu zu
beginnen und werden sie in der schweiz
ihr glück finden
[Musik]
wir haben menschen aus vier ländern bei
ihrem neuanfang in der schweiz begleitet
[Musik]
was bisher geschah wer ihm indien fahren
kann kann überall fahren vor einem jahr
bereiteten sich raúl und seine frau mega
auf ihren neustart in der schweiz vor
der manager übernahm eine stelle als ceo
einer schweizer firma seine frau mega
ebenfalls managerin war ein luxuriöses
leben gewohnt
ich habe in meinem ganzen leben noch nie
gekocht freunde haben mir erzählt wird
in der schweiz jeder selber kochen
nach einigen monaten der vorbereitung
empfängt seine frauen in der schweiz
jetzt wird sich zeigen wie mega den
sprung schafft sich nicht einsam ihr
baby an wochenenden schon lieber
arbeitet seit zwei jahren in einem
alters- und pflegeheim in graubünden
[Musik]
liga ist 50 geschieden und mutter von
zwei erwachsenen söhnen in portugal 20
keine arbeit
jeden monat schickt sie die hälfte ihres
gehalts nach hause um ihre mutter und
ihre söhne finanziell zu unterstützen
in der schweiz fehlt ihr die liebe
[Musik]
besonders in einem fremden land
ich war hier genau hier und der türke
dahinten familie als er flüchtete vor
drei jahren von syrien über das
mittelmeer nach europa inzwischen hat im
tessin asyl erhalten
die beiden töchter an und drazan
sprechen fließend italienisch und liegen
den spagat zwischen den kulturen
diese woche haben wir viele schöne und
waren die dinge gemacht sogar abends bis
mitternacht wenn die mutter agiert rückt
in der schweiz die schulbank
ein italienischkurs soll ihr die
integration erleichtern
die franzosen jury und fabia haben in
der schweiz problemlos arbeit gefunden
in der stadt el haben sie sich ein neues
leben aufgebaut den tisch hierhin denn
wirklich mich zu nahe kam nach der
heirat schmieden beide weitere pläne
wenn wir dann vielleicht mal ein baby
haben
inzwischen ist sie schwanger
und genau jetzt wird fabian die
sicherheit seines jobs als ingenieur
über bord um sich als kunstschmied
selbstständig zu machen
[Musik]
mit vertiefungen und rundungen mit
kleinen punkten
hört sich an wie ein
sicherheitsschlüssel vielleicht aber
auch nicht
ich werde meine arbeit gerät in den
wagen laden dann komme ich vorbei dich
gleich
ich muss eine dame helfen die sich
aufgeschlossen hat das heißt 20 minuten
20 minuten vor ort insgesamt eine stunde
in der zeit stammt und eine stunde
später fabia hat ein schlechtes gewissen
anstatt das wochenende mit seiner
schwangeren frau zu verbringen
arbeitet ihr für seinen schlüssel
notdienst noch fehlt es an kunden für
seine kunstschmiede deshalb ist er auf
die einnahmen angewiesen
ich kenne mich hier noch nicht so gut
aus deshalb weiß ich nur mit gps wie
lang die fahrzeit ist
ich habe jetzt mal 30 minuten gesagt
fallen
30 minuten für jeden fleck im kanton
reichen wahrscheinlich geht aber
schneller
fabia blüht auf in seiner neuen arbeit
die finanzielle sicherheit eines
ingenieur jobs fehlt dafür lebt ihr
seinen traum
ich wollte da was wein sprühen
ich hab's vergessen
40 das hätte geholfen oder da bin ich
mir nicht sicher
das ist dieser hack das nächste mal
funktioniert dann wieder
ich verstehe nicht warum das plötzlich
blockiert waren nicht mehr aufgeht
schauen wir uns mal näher an
[Musik]
auch das gefällt verliere
jetzt kommt er endlich mit schweizern in
kontakt als ingenieur war er fast
ausschließlich von französischen
grenzgängern umgeben
dass wir noch ein paar minuten dauern
kein problem schließlich soll das dann
auch nicht jeder öffnen können der
vorbeikommt die tür hat schon ein paar
jährchen allerdings
[Musik]
kein problem der mega entdeckt ihr neues
leben in der schweiz
in indien war ich total verwöhnt
beruflich war ich super aber was dem
staat an geht vergisst ehrlich das ist
eine ganz schöne verantwortung
also fangen wir mit den basics bibeln
kartoffeln pauls eltern waren immer da
und meine eltern waren auch nicht weit
ich fühle mich hier sehr einsam ganz
ehrlich bin da wohl bei der arbeit ist
und ich alleine mit dir zu hause bin
das fühlt sich sehr einsam an manchmal
denke ich ich wäre besser in indien
geblieben
knapp zwei wochen nach ihrer ankunft
werden megas befürchtungen wahr daily
hatte ich nicht mal zeit ein buch zu
lesen
die arbeit und ihr haben einen tag
aufgeführt jetzt habe ich alle zeit der
welt ich fühle mich wahnsinnig einsam
mal ehrlich wieviel zeit kann man denn
mit seinen freunden im internet
verbringen
die haben doch alle ihr leben das ist
wirklich nicht einfach
[Musik]
mega lässt sich nicht unterkriegen
sie macht sich intensiv auf jobsuche
eine geregelte arbeit soll sie auch in
ihrem neuen leben wieder ausfüllen eine
hoffnung an die er sich festklammert die
syrische familie als nimmt die lugano an
einer kundgebung für ihre heimatstadt
alle parteien
dort spielt sich eine humanitäre
katastrophe ab
[Musik]
kein tag an dem die als echt nicht in
gedanken in syrien sind boni und
maschinengewehre
das ist dass millionen von menschen in
syrien tagtäglich und seit jahren hören
sie versuche mich in sicherheit gebracht
sich zu schützen so gut sie können
und manchmal bleibt die nur zu geben die
familie wird sowohl von syrischen wie
auch von schweizer freunden begleitet
komm ans mikrofon junge dame wie heißt
du denn schönes lächeln du hast ich
möchte allen danken dass ihr heute für
alle gekommen seid
ich habe zwei brüder mit kindern in
syrien sind gut möglich den krieg
getötet werden
meine mutter war den ganzen tag ich
danke euch
[Applaus]
die familie ist sich ihres glücks
bewusst in der schweiz asyl gefunden zu
haben und sie vergessen jene nicht die
noch immer im krieg in syrien ausharren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
alles ab 1
wieder erwartet besuch aus portugal
sie freut sich es ist das erste mal seit
ihrer ankunft vor zwei jahren
ihr jüngerer sohn eduardo möchte das
neue leben seiner mutter kennenlernen
[Musik]
vor einer halben stunde später hat herr
lass uns zuerst mal was essen
wie wär's mit einer wurst oder so lisa
hat urlaub genommen und zeit für ihren
sohn zu haben
ihr habt ihr gefegt die schweiz braucht
man für alles eine bewilligung da gibt
es sogar witze drüber zb kommt der erste
schweizer auf den mond alte die flanke
rein stecken will sagt er ich habe
vergessen eine bewilligung einzuholen
lisa wohnt eine halbe stunde von hoher
entfernt
ihre wohnung ist zu klein um beide söhne
gleichzeitig zu beherbergen
der ältere wird ein anderes mal kommen
schön hast du s ich finde das ist eine
süße wohnung auf den fotos war das nicht
so schön aus sie am besten mal die
schuhe aus gewinn für die ganze boden
zumal das funktioniert so
ich wusste gar nicht dass du so verhasst
werden ganz einfach er macht es nicht
kompliziert wie gestern abend zu hause
habe ich mit ihm noch geredet er hatte
noch nicht gefragt der hatte noch nichts
gemacht nur einfach seinen check in
ausgedruckt und sonst gar nichts gemacht
also wenn du dieses kissen haben
möchtest kannst du damit schlafen wir
können zwei leute schlange wartete seit
klein heute immer schnee ferien machen
er wollte unbedingt schnee wenn er nicht
als kleine mal gefragt wie fühlt sich
dann sagen wie ist das ist überhaupt
ich habe in meinem ganzen leben noch nie
gesehen wie schnell so richtig schön vom
himmel fällt
ich bin stolz auf das was ich erreicht
habe und es freut mich dass sich die bei
mir habe und die das miterleben einfach
dass das freut mich dass ihn zeigen kann
und dann denke ich als ich sogar was was
gutes was nicht jede mutter einem sohn
oder ein kind geben kann in einem land
wohnen und ihn einladen woanders nicht
mehr schweizer kommt er nicht die
schweiz kennen lernen also bin ich doch
eine rasche mutter hat ihm doch glück
gehabt mit mir
die moderne technik nach feierabend
besuchen jury und fabian das geburtshaus
wo ihr gemeinsames kind zur welt kommen
soll
das wird ja es mitten im winter seien
auf ein büro eine küche klingeln und ein
trieb es soll ein besonderer ort sein
sie haben sie angemeldet eine der
hebammen führt sie herum für autobanken
wahrscheinlich empfinden
okay da gibt es dann kein zurück mehr
das hier ist für die tour zahlen dort
eine badewanne nicht ertrinken ist der
maya stohl kennen wieder mit dem kann
man im sitzen gewähren
ehrlich gesagt habe ich mich noch nicht
mit den verschiedenen arten zu gebären
beschäftigt ich kann mir das noch gar
nicht richtig vorstellen
das erscheint mir irgendwie noch ganz
weit weg aber ich führe ihn gerne zu und
das ist normal das kommt später von
alleine
plötzlich können sie es sich dann
vorstellen wie viele hebammen sind bei
der geburt vorbei und der vater kann die
ganze platte rey seien aber sicher
das habe ich auch vor außerdem letztlich
also wenn er
unternehmen müssen außerdem nicht wohl
dabei ist sonst schon einer der vorteile
des geburtshauses der vater kann die
ersten acht bei ihnen und dem kind im
zimmer verbringen
das ist gut
die erste nach der familie stehen hier
häufig stimmt nicht so viel los wie in
einem spital und dann fühlt sich für
oktober einschreiben
[Musik]
ich habe da seite gesehen analogen
wünsch dir was vor dem geburtstag genau
der richtige ort
[Musik]
wieder hat für ihren sohn ein straffes
programm zusammengestellt um so viel
geht deutlich immer zu fuß
klar 7.7 auf der station
das ist eine art arcade da geht es in
die altstadt
hier unten
das ist alles für den technischen
service alles was es braucht damit das
ganze funktioniert
nein ich habe eine woche
das hier ist auf deutsch darunter auf
romanisch das klingt ein bisschen die
produkte zeigt die alten von ela
bündnerischen human hinein romanisch ihr
sprechen alle romanischen
schweizerdeutsch dazu noch statt
das ist die offizielle amtssprache
lieber möchte ihrem sohn seinen lang
gehegten wunsch erfüllen
zum ersten mal in seinem leben soll er
mächtigen schlesien auch warum möchte
seiner frau einen wunsch erfüllen sie
war zum ersten mal in ihrem leben auf
skiern stehen
schau mal da ist noch eine bahn und
schau mal hinter dir
wahnsinn wir sind über den wolken
der ausflug zum mega auf andere gedanken
bringen wie tut sich schwer mit dem
leben in der schweiz und hat heimweh wie
echte profis kommen hier mit
plastiktüten drauf ganz so unvorbereitet
ist raul dann doch nicht für seine frau
hatte er sowohl die ausrüstung wie auch
eine private skistunde reserviert ich
hab noch nie so was schwere seinen füßen
gehabt zumal die ja da sind meine
skischuhe augen zu und bergab wenn du
bremsen willst einfach nur die hieraus
ziehen ich mir gar nicht erst einmal
umdrehen bitte genau das hier ist vorne
im graubünden wagen sich auch lisa und
eduardo auf die pisten nicht so einfach
die ersten übungen auf dem snowboard
stehen an immerhin eduardo hat
erfahrungen mit dem skateboard
darauf baut ihr zum ersten mal in der
schweiz ja zum ersten mal im schnee
überhaupt zum ersten mal am besten genau
wie auf dem skateboard gewicht auf den
zehen dann auf die ferse verlagern und
dann den oberkörper in die kurse drehen
so geht das
lisa hat für ihren sohn skikleidung von
einem freund geliehen
es kann losgehen vielleicht solltest du
in flachen anfangen und erstmal
irgendwie hin zu stellen
so gezielt oder
ich habe spaß daran dass ich ihn was
anbieten kann was er noch nicht ganz was
neues machen kann
[Musik]
ich dachte das wäre viel einfacher
ich bin jetzt schon ziemlich fertig aber
weiter geht's eine stunde später
eduardo macht fortschritte ich war noch
nie an zu einem ich finde es toll ich
die berge der schnee ich mag alles hier
kannst du mich hochziehen
ich kann sie ziehen aber so lernst du
nicht dass du siehst mich in die falsche
richtung das ging besser ohne dies jetzt
zu ihnen
[Musik]
das hat spaß gemacht
das ist für mich eine art glücksgefühl
schwer zu beschreiben dass gleich die
traurigen momente aus das ist eine
spannende erfahrung nicht anstrengen so
lässt sich megas probleme bewusst
ich weiß dass sie sich noch oft einsam
fühlt und dass sie hier einiges aus
indien vermisst das sehe ich natürlich
wir müssen jetzt schauen wie sich das in
den kommenden wochen und monaten
entwickelte es dann werden wir wissen ob
sie wirklich angekommen ist oder nicht
muss ich die parallel halten
außerdem hat mega noch eine gute
nachricht erhalten eine einladung an ein
vorstellungsgespräch
[Gelächter]
wenn ich nicht studieren müsste würde
ich hierher ziehen
das ist aber ein teurer sport wie alles
hier
deshalb sage ich ja immer dass hier kaum
raus gehe dann musst du genau aussuchen
und 100 euro budget planen
einmal pro monat zb hierherkommen und
snowboarden oder skifahren
jetzt kriege ich endlich ein bisschen
von ihrem leben mit auch wie sie
arbeitet ich denke sie hat die richtige
entscheidung getroffen
auch wenn ich weiß dass es oft hart ist
für sie ich möchte sie moralisch
unterstützen die auf meiner seite in
portugal alles so machen dass sie sich
um uns keine sorgen machen muss und hier
ihr leben leben kann
[Musik]
furchtbares foto dunkel
mohammed und seine familie nehmen an
einem fels teil das sie gemeinsam mit
ihren freunden organisiert haben
wir warten auf rica hat heute geburtstag
und wir haben eine überraschung für sie
vorbereitet
[Musik]
frederica engagiert sich für flüchtlinge
sie hilft ihnen bei behördengängen bei
der wohnungssuche und beim italienisch
lernen
mit der zeit sind so viele
freundschaften entstanden
wir haben ein paar typische speisen für
die vorbereitet unter anderem auch tabu
das haben wir speziell für veritas
geburtstag gekocht person ich hab
wirklich gerne
wir fanden das anders in eine reihe
stellen und sie muss an alles mit
verbundenen augen probieren die kinder
hören
ich verlasse mich auf dich komm einfach
mit
seid ihr denn vor allem im bereich du
musst jetzt etwas berühren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
solche momente sind balsam für die vom
krieg verwüsteten seelen der als sales
gerne hätten sie mehr davon
doch die integration ist nicht immer
einfach
[Applaus]
mega ist inzwischen seit drei monaten in
der schweiz heute ist ein guter tag
meine größte angst die schweiz angeht
war das ist das ende meiner beruflichen
karriere ist jetzt habe ich gerade die
zusage für einen job bei einer
internationalen firma bekommen das macht
mich sehr glücklich ich liebe es zu
arbeiten und ich freue mich schon sehr
darauf hier in der schweiz tätig zu sein
ihre beruflichen erfahrungen und ihre
guten englischkenntnisse haben ihr
geholfen einen job zu finden
jetzt werden und wie sich neu
organisieren müssen in zukunft wird mega
vollzeit arbeiten und die ja nicht mehr
am nachmittag von der schule abholen
können
[Musik]
april dürfte geschichte bier hat sich
bestens eingelebt sie geht gerne zur
internationalen schule an der schule
wird vor allem auf englisch unterrichtet
aber auch deutsch steht als schulfach
auf dem unterrichtsplan
die erfolgreiche managerin mega
definiert sich zu großen teilen über
ihre arbeit
sie ist froh dass ihre größte
befürchtung ein neustart in der schweiz
nicht eingetreten ist
jetzt müssen wir noch die betreuung von
tochter dia organisieren so langsam
ändert sich alles ein
vielleicht klingt so als ob die arbeit
mein leben definiert eigentlich tut
sogar es geht darum etwas zu tun was ich
vorantreibt inspiriert und am ende
finanziell unabhängig macht arbeit ist
ganz sicher ein wichtiger teil unseres
lebens
[Musik]
ab wann sind einwanderer wirklich
integriert
wenn sie unsere sprache sprechen wenn
sie bei uns eine arbeit haben hier zur
schule gehen
wenn die schweizer freunde haben oder
wenn sie von unserem land als zu hause
sprechen
ein jahr lang haben wir ein wanderer aus
verschiedenen kulturen und sozialen
schichten bei ihrem neustart in der
schweiz begleitet
technischer bayerische kultur
die hat er da wieder mit frau
[Musik]
[Applaus]
reimann und rasern haben den sprung über
den graben der kulturen geschafft
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich kennen gelernt als ich für ihn
gemüse mit dem auto geholt habe
das werde ich nie vergessen dann bin ich
zu euch nach hause gekommen
ich weiß nicht mehr was ich gestern
gegessen habe und ich habe ein jahr
gebraucht um zu kapieren wer von euch
schavan und vera sammet war das am
anfang sehr schwierig mit der sprache
und so aber jetzt habe ich viele freunde
und ich verstehe mich mit allen gut
auch für mich war das sehr schwierig zu
beginn ohne die sprache zu sprechen
ich habe nicht verstanden wenn sie
lachten oder irgendwelche dinge warten
ich habe das einfach nicht verstanden
nicht immer miteinander im bus gefahren
als ich dann italienisch gelernt habe
oder alles einfacher ich habe gelernt
sie nicht mehr als ausländer zu sehen
für mich sind das keine dürer oder
afghanen mehr sondern haben brava oder
video einfach menschen
sag mal was auf arabisch
die alpha in der schweiz haben sie ein
stückchen heimat gefunden
[Musik]
für unseren letzten besuch empfangen und
fabian jury bei sich zu hause vor dem
kamin
in der schweiz haben sich die beiden ein
sicheres nest gebaut
während in ihrer alten heimat frankreich
vieles im umbruch ist
[Musik]
wenn man so zurückschaut hat man das
gefühl dass wir es vor allem vertragen
in die schweiz gekommen sind arbeiten
seit 1 jahr und 4 tage
die beiden sind sich einig wie es
weitergehen soll
ganz sicher in der schweiz vor allem aus
zwei gründen zum einen nicht
gravierender bei sich hier beruflich
eine zukunft aufzubauen
da geht man nicht einfach nach ein paar
monaten wieder weg nicht so schnell
kontakte kundschaft aufbauen
die cavs in gang bringen braucht seine
zeit seit ich vor zwei monaten in die
eigenständigkeit gestartet bin
aber ich mir schweizer kennen gelernt
dass während eines jahres bei meinem
alten job für die integration ist dass
sie besser und zweitens erwarten
nachwuchs
da werden wir nicht direkt schon wieder
umziehen wir möchten das land ja auch
genießen
das baby soll auch nicht kennenlernen
sicher wird sich auch unser schweizer
freundeskreis vergrößern durch die
begegnungen mit anderen mitteln
ich denke dass wir dann zum beispiel
über die krippe viele andere eltern
kennenlernen werden ich bin ziemlich
sicher dass wir durch das baby hiermit
hat er viele neue kontakte knüpfen
werden
unser baby wird in einem sicheren land
aufwachsen frau ein kleiner franzose
umgeben von schweizern oder vielleicht
ist es ja auch ein lied mit
schweizerischer seiner rede
[Musik]
auch mega und raul treffen wir noch ein
letztes mal gelöscht
ein jahr voller wandel von neu delhi
nach zürich und der chef hat auch immer
ich koche erst meist einfach
irgendwelche gewürze wein und brot vor
sie macht das grobe und dann wenn es um
die feinheiten geht habe ich meinen
großen auftritt ich koche eigentlich nur
wenn die beiden mit dabei sind auch wenn
indische gerichte recht kompliziert
aussehen
am ende sind sie ziemlich einfach zu
kochen ich glaube ich bin hier
organisiert und respektvoller geworden
als ich in indien war zum beispiel bei
der arbeit
das tue ich jetzt meine kaffeetasse
zurück in die spüle oder wasche sie
sogar mit omega haben wir gelacht als
wir uns vorgestellt haben wie schockiert
den indien derjenige schauen würde der
für so was zuständig ist ich dass dort
machen würde
er würde sich fragen warum macht er das
das ist doch mein job
ich bin noch nicht fertig weg da ich
sehe hier viele positive dinge die hohe
der frieden die schöne natur wie gut
alles organisiert ist das alles genieße
ich sehr
auf der anderen seite muss man hier
selber kochen und gut aber mit der zeit
ist das nicht mehr so schlimm
auch der hat einen wandel durchgemacht
wirklich ein papa kind geworden hier
unglaublich wir für die hat sich sicher
meisten verändert
beispiel schläft jetzt zum ersten mal in
ihrem eigenen zimmer
allerdings vergisst sich hierhin in der
schule spricht sie den ganzen tag
englisch
das ist jetzt ihre umgangssprache es
läuft gut für die inder
man könnte meinen sie verwandeln sich
ein wenig in schweizer hand schweizer zu
einem teil
ich denke das trifft und ihre zuschauer
können sich jetzt überlegen was halb
schweizer bedeutet
[Musik]
und auch lisa zeit für uns ein letztes
mal vor die kamera
ihr sohn ist zurück in portugal jetzt
ist sie vor allem wieder 1 alleine hat
mich bauch gemacht dass mein sohn nicht
hier bewirkt hat das erste mal also nur
eine von meinen also statt ein monolog
und ich einen dialog machen auch meine
wahrnehmung und empfindungen uns alle
meine erfahrung hin der schweiz
die integration ist möglich aber du
musst auch was dafür tun
du musst dir muss klar sein
du bist in einen wien jedem fremden land
du musst dich anpassen
aber du musst auch aufpassen dass du
jetzt nicht nur die ganze zeit anpasst
dass du auch deinen 1 kulturell vermögen
behält und dann immer noch ein bisschen
wie soll ich sagen behalten darf und
auch ein bisschen durchsetzen darf ab ja
aber ich habe auch was dafür weiter an
alleine seien in einem fremden land also
nicht in deiner heimat das bedeutet
ziemlich viel und gibt es gelernt und
jetzt bin ich auch gerne und zufrieden
mit mir alleine
jetzt habe ich gelernt wird sich anfühlt
und wie man sich auch werk ich mache
schon vieles aus meiner weise ist auch
egal
außerdem denke ich abschluss dichter als
darf man findet was man unter 50 eben
nicht doch mal in die schweiz kommen
[Musik]
neben
juni
richtig
[Musik]
l
mehr
[Musik]